[Música]
por qué nos cuesta tanto amarnos no sé
si alguna vez a ustedes les han
preguntado
como se ven inmediatamente contestan ay
si te gusta como que no me gusta tanto y
empiezan a buscar pretextos para
realmente no creernos las ay me ha
pasado muchísimas veces y no les voy a
mentir me sigue pasando pero es algo con
lo que podemos luchar todos los días hay
una frase de joaquín sabina que hace más
de diez años a mí me ha retado muchísimo
en la cabeza
la frase dice si el mundo fuera ciego a
quien impresionar y yo creo que quiero
que hoy tú tengas esta pregunta si el
mundo fuera ciego y no hablo de una
ceguera física
a quien impresionar y as porque muchas
veces al menos inconscientemente no sé
si les pasó también en esta pandemia
dejamos de usar muchísima ropa que a lo
mejor compramos antes de que ya no
estaba la moda y ya nunca nadie nos las
vio puestas y qué aburrido que se
quedaron ahí en el closet y que
sentíamos que a veces por eso que
teníamos o por eso que los cursos que
tomamos o por las clases que ya no
tuvimos presenciales o los talleres no
valemos lo mismo o no somos
suficientemente capaces para hacer algo
la pregunta quién eres es algo que me ha
retumbado muchísimo en la cabeza sobre
todo la primera vez que hizo una
entrevista de trabajo que llegué puse
mis papeles di mi currículum y el
entrevistador me preguntó del perfecto
nutrióloga tales certificados al
diplomado pero tú quién eres
y yo quería repetir lo mismo de que no
creo lo de mi certificado está el
diplomado está la escuela y como la
pregunta quién eres yo me la seguía
preguntando y yo no tenía una respuesta
en sí porque muchas veces el mundo nos
pinta como tienes que ser de cierta u
otra manera o vales por los cursos que
tienes o por los diplomados que tienes
son las empresas que tienes terminando
de describir la universidad por ejemplo
habría una cafetería
y en pandemias cierran y yo ya me sentía
la empresaria dueña de la cafetería y
cierra y me quedé bueno y ahora quién
soy o sea sólo a la nutrióloga o si ya
no tengo pacientes tampoco soy
nutrióloga ahora quién soy y es
importante saber nos que somos por el
simple hecho de ser personas porque mi
estrella entidad no te no depende de las
cosas que tenemos o de lo que damos sino
de que somos por el simple hecho de
haber nacido porque se nos creó porque
fuimos amados
quiero que ésta
frase que voy a decir a continuación es
algo que se los recuerde cada vez que
vean el reloj a mí es algo que me pone
la piel de punta cada 40 segundos según
dar a la organización de la salud una
persona se suicida en el mundo
imagínese en estate cada 18 segundos hay
27 personas que se han quitado la vida y
no solamente queda ahí sino que más de
25 por ciento de estas probabilidades
son debido a una disculpa corporal o
debido a alguien que no se puede ver al
espejo
yo no me quiero ir muy lejos yo para ser
por ahí yo pasé más de un año sin poder
ver al espejo cuando tenía 15 años
yo no podía verlo podía aceptar que
alguien me dijera que bonita porque yo
sentía que estaban ofendiendo yo sentía
que me estaban burlando que me estaban
humillando
imagínense que apenas acabo de ver una
tv c's que decía cómo prevenir un
suicidio
y la clave además de llamar al número de
emergencia es esperar a que lleguen en
lo que estás ahí esperando que la
persona sea venta o estás ahí viendo lo
que está pasando es acercarte con la
persona y decirle tu vida es importante
para mí
y que es fuerte eso no todos necesitamos
ese ser importante es para alguien todos
tenemos un anhelo profundo en el corazón
que buscamos pertenecer lo que buscamos
siempre estar en un lugar al inicio la
pandemia fue la primera vez que arme un
rompecabezas por mi familia y me acuerdo
que me estreso muchísimo porque yo no
soy paciente es una virtud que tengo que
trabajar pero el momento de poner las
piezas del rompecabezas me di cuenta y
yo quería fuerza poner una presencia
similar en el color en el tamaño en la
forma y yo le dije a mi hermano bueno es
que si le cortamos este lado queda
perfecto y el mediano o sea es que hay
una pieza ideal para ese lugar y a veces
queremos tanto encajar en un lugar que
no es nuestra pieza tu pieza fue hecha
para ser completamente en su esplendor
en otro lado del rompecabezas y a veces
estamos tan enfocados en una pieza si
está chiquita que se nos olvida todo lo
demás
yo y te quiero dar cinco pasos que a mí
me han ayudado para conocerme para poder
ahí amarme porque a veces nos pintan el
amor propio sobre todo en la actualidad
como algo que tiene que ser y amate
amate amate y mírate al espejo y
aceptarte tal cual eres y hasta las
cosas y valora te etcétera y está
padrísimo decir tenemos que hacer
pero no los dicen como si fuera algo que
fueras a la farmacia y comprar cinco
textos de amor propio o fuera algo súper
fácil y hay una frase es súper cierta
que dice nadie puede amar algo que no
conoce y si no nos conocemos cómo nos
vamos a poder amar
estos cinco pasos de los boyeros
desmenuzando porque a mí me han ayudado
muchísimo yo sé que a ti te van a ayudar
tanto como a mí el primero es mirarte y
no solo verte porque mirarte porque la
palabra arte según la real academia
española significa cav y capacidad o
habilidad para lograr un objetivo
y poder buscar esa capacidad o habilidad
en ti para lograr tus objetivos es algo
que si no tú no te das cuenta y sólo
pasas al espejo te ves y te critica 5
partes de tu cuerpo o no sutiles pues
toda esta actividad alguna vez en la
escuela o en la primaria de que pones tu
mano y en un lado pones como 5 cosas que
te gustan de ti y al otro lado 5 cosas
que no te gustan y las cosas que te
gustan te cuesta como toda la clase
hacerlas y las cosas que no te gustan
casi que te faltan hojas para llenarlas
entonces buscar la capacidad o habilidad
que va más allá de solamente lo que el
espejo pinta lo que el espejo te
presenta a veces pasamos y seguro no se
acuerda ni qué ropa traen ayer ni qué
ropa se pusieron ni qué ropa traían en
la foto hace dos días porque a veces
solamente nos vemos y no vemos esa
capacidad y esa habilidad para tener y
lograr lo que tenemos que hacer en la
vida
también es importante como segundo paso
identificar tus máscaras porque porque
muchas veces nos dicen pues estoy bien
no necesito a nadie ni nada
la máscara de que todo está bien la
máscara de que si alguien te pregunta
cómo estás siempre estás bien nunca
necesitas a nadie siempre pues solo
siempre tienes que trabajar más hacer
más y ganar más porque a lo mejor de
chiquito te hicieron casi varias más y
no te culpo porque muchas veces hay
heridas en el pasado que nos hacen
buscar ese llenar vacíos por el simple
hecho de sentirnos más suficientes
porque a lo mejor queríamos que entre
más cosas hacemos más cosas valemos
entonces es importante identificar estas
máscaras para reconocer que no importa
cuánto hagas o deje de hacer ella eres
suficiente así como les digo de las
heridas
es importante abrazar tu pasado porque
es importante abrazarlo porque muchas
veces nos las pasamos culpando a nuestro
pasado culpando a nuestros papás a lo
mejor abuelos a lo mejor tíos a lo mejor
alguna persona que nos hizo daño alguna
persona con sucio bullying
y es difícil es difícil verlo y
enfrentar ese pasado que a lo mejor
duele porque las heridas pues duelen y
si alguien llega a mejorar por darte
salida es algo qué dices oye no sé qué
pasó no sé qué hiciste pero hay algo
aquí que me duele
porque hay un pasado hay una herida que
te está recordando constantemente eso
que te dolió eso que no te gustó eso se
hizo sentir menos
y es importante abrazarlo y acoger tu
vida tu cuenta que no eres eso tu pasado
te hace ser quien tú eres el día de hoy
pero no te hace tú tú no eres tu pasado
tu pasado te hace llegar hasta aquí te
hace reconocer el poder ver ok qué son
las cosas que pude haber hecho mejor que
son las cosas que hice bien
que puedo mejorar el día de mañana
prestar mejor ahí es donde tenemos que
abrazar nuestro pasado también es
importante recordar como cuarto punto
que somos totalmente imperfectos pero
somos perfectibles porque por qué dijo
esto porque muchas veces nos podemos
tirar al suelo y podemos decir no es que
soy imperfecto nunca puedo hacer nada
nunca puedo lograr nada pues ya para que
hago algo o ya me dijeron que estoy bien
que me amo y ya me aceptó y / estoy bien
esto no cambió nada y es importante
recordar que siempre somos perfectibles
a nacimos imperfectos y está bien y toda
la vida lo vamos a hacer pero siempre
podemos buscar y luchar para ser mejores
porque de nada sirve identificar algo
que podemos crecer si nos quedamos donde
siempre estamos
y de nada sirve que como les decía al
inicio todos tenemos un deseo profundo
de ser amados y de encajar y de
pertenecer de nada sirve saber nos
amados y conocernos si no podemos tener
la capacidad o la habilidad de reconocer
el valor de los demás y de recordarles
también que son suficientes
recordemos que en este mundo no estamos
solos sino que venimos en comunidad y
cada uno de nosotros tiene un sentido y
un valor en esta vida yo por ejemplo
algo que a mí me da muchísimo miedo
sobre todo de estar contando a lo mejor
un poco del pase un año sin poderme ver
al espejo y me cuesta y me duele
recordarlo
pero muchas veces el dolor más profundo
o la vulnerabilidad a lo mejor de tu
vida es lo que hace que hoy tu luz sea
como mucho más grande cuando mejores es
tu propósito en la vida
por ejemplo en mí el estar aquí el día
de hoy o el volver a contar esta
historia además de qué
para sanz chiquito
siento
que tu vida puede ser la historia de
salvación de otra persona y si tú te
quedas callada y si tú no la cuentas
las personas pueden quedarse también con
su vida y quedarse calladas y todos
tienen un potencial nuevo que transmitir
y es importante recordar que tu vida es
importante que tuvieses valioso que eres
capaz que eres digno que eres único y
quieres suficiente pero te hace falta
conocerte y de ahí poder conocer y
reconocer el valor de los demás
gracias
[Aplausos]